bismillah hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you you know already if
you've been tuning into the Deen show
this is the best greeting that one could
give is that greeting a peace jesus
greeted his followers with that greeting
of peace so that Moses Abraham and the
last and final messenger sent a man kind
of problem Hamid peace be upon them all
you're tuning in to the deed show it's
exciting that you wake up every day and
the creator of the heavens and earth is
giving you another day to live the way
of life the purpose of life that's
pleasing to him so then you can be
successful in this life and then have
the ultimate reward in the paradise in
the next but talk is cheap you got to
back it up with action so we're going to
be giving you the blueprint on how you
can be successful you depressed this is
the antidote to depression are you
having a hard time and you just don't
know you're going out of your mind we
got the formula to help you live a
better life so you can be successful in
this life and the next don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with my special
guest here in the Dean show
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
I like good salami how you doing how are
you Sheikh I'm did it laughs I'm gonna
shake Kareem Abu Zeid yes here on the
Deen show many people know you from hood
TV and your lecture all over America
tell us just a little bit about yourself
I'm the Imam of Colorado Muslim society
I was born in Egypt I've been in America
almost for 20 years and I'm just a
student of knowledge so well you're a
student that we want to learn from well
you are share and we want to benefit
from what you have you've been studying
Islam for you know the way of life of
all the messengers the way of life
that's pleasing to the crater submission
to the will of God so you have the
experience we want to get some of this
you also you know help people who come
come to Islam people who are in Islam
but you heard me mention that talk is
cheap you got to back it up with action
you can't just say look I believe and
then there's nothing behind that is that
correct it is absolutely a very accurate
statement and that goes to anyone who
wants to become a Muslim to harvest the
fruit of submission obedience adherence
which is peace in this world like you
said and of course the ultimate success
in the next life which is the
everlasting abode
Jenna you have to do the work the work
you have to commit yourself to the
religion you have to live like a Muslim
you cannot pretend to be one you have to
be one in actual you have to
fulfill the commands that's when you
begin and this actually was coated in a
beautiful hadith and this [ __ ] fee
sahih bukhari hadith of the harem
rhodiola Han Allah subhanAllah Allah
says when I deliver a lien for Fidel and
to who will help and then subhana Allah
says my servant will not find anything
that will bring him closer to me than
what I have prescribed upon him so we're
talking about the five daily prayers
here start from there if you have not
started if you want to start right there
five daily prayers for are not enough
three are not enough - or not
five five daily prayers basics then you
can increase no offence women you can do
that but you have to start with the
basics and of course the rest
zakah the 2.5% the mandatory fasting
Ramadan and Hajj if you're able to so
you have to begin submitting to a lot of
Hannibal -
tell us sheikh now before we get into
these bit we're just talking about basic
things these are basic thing the basic
fundamentals and you build off that if
you don't have a good foundation how you
gonna build the house right so we're
going to talk about the basic things
that the driving force behind this way
of life but now we cater to a lot of not
yet Muslims because I say look everyone
has the ability to submit to God now you
make a choice you want to submit to
yourself your desires - women - money -
faint the power or you want to submit to
the one who gave you life will give you
death the one you're going to have to go
back and answer - today a judgement
paradise or Hellfire so we want people
in paradise and we want ourselves first
and foremost and we care that's why
we're sharing so for the not yet Muslims
comes there's many stereotypes so now
they say they think Muslim and right
away you know what goes with that
terrorist you know so they see like us
sitting here and they see you know the
they used to flick in the channel they
don't see like the Hat and the beard and
they say man so the Muslim got his
friend like to sit down and watch so now
in his head he's just thinking terrorist
man what am i watching here these guys
are Qaeda or something what's going on
well you laugh it tell us tell us now
let's do you what do you got to say
about this when somebody starts to you
know have this in the in the
there had some Express it is a terrorist
Muslim what do you say about this I
really want to say who are you on the
side of Allah I really care about who am
i in the side of my Creator Allah told
me in the Quran that you belong to the
best o ma kuntum hire our own Mateen or
idiot leanness a more honorable man what
an animal you are the best oh ma you are
Muslims the best Ummah and talking to
your brothers and I'm talking to the
audience as well you see Allah praised
me but not because of my birth because
of I do the things which makes me a
Muslim again which makes me the best
Amma
in that context like to be a Muslim you
have to do we said earlier the work
exactly if you want to belong to the
best all might have to enjoin good
forbid evil you have to believe in Allah
that's who I am and the side of Allah
listen you're here to please your role
your Lord you're not here to please the
people and actually our messenger told
us that if you try what had it is
officially tell me the hydration of the
alarm if you actually try to please
people at the expense of allah allah
subhana wa tada will make those people
displeased with you when our Vanessa be
so hot in let us hot Allahu Allah
heinous the same person like a typical
Muslim now he shied away from praying at
work because he's afraid to make his
boss upset I'm telling you you're making
your boss happy at the expense of Allah
your boss will fire please Allah and if
you try to please Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala but he act like a Muslim so don't
act like a weirdo I mean let's level
this let's balance you have you have
tried to have the character of a Muslim
you see if you want to look like a
Muslim also have the character of a
Muslim I'm sorry some of these judgments
that non-muslims make up they have some
ground for it we have Muslims who do not
act like Muslims his name is Mohammed
but he's not acting like one
we got to also have the character as
well if you do this if you if you're a
Muslim you're in the business of
pleasing your Lord and you carry
yourself as a Muslim character wise I
care less what people say one day so
what about now that's for the the Muslim
what about the anonymous had never heard
this word Allah he never you know had
this experience with any of these Arabic
terms but all he saw was Fox News CNN
and they show things blowing up and they
show a guy with a beard Arab looking and
they right away stigmatized and they
think like Arab Muslim terrorists these
are this is we're talking to the
non-muslim now what have you had this
experience to what do you tell them I
hear with them you know I was brought up
in Egypt yeah and this is a real story
here tell us tell us yeah and they told
us throughout history that Brits are bad
the Brits are bad the Brits pretty but
the British heritage here they occupied
Egypt they killed those people
it's brain storming brainwash
brainwashing you're in washed so you
know I went to school in Cairo and I
it's maybe the first time I revealed
myself I was by profession I used to be
a tour guide in Egypt guess who was my
first clients a British British no way
we're still friends still now yeah I
mean friends in the sense of we
communicate I mean low-key kind of thing
but listen you taste hate if you hate
you taste the bitterness of hey if you
hate you taste that you taste that
you're gonna be you're not gonna be
happy and it is unfair and I'm really
speaking to you here it is unfair to
hate somebody who does not deserve your
hate listen I'm like you you know I'm
like Patricia and Joe you know I take
the trash out every day you know you try
to clean the house and I'm just somebody
who's trying to please his Lord you know
and this is my path to happiness in this
world and I want the
life I'm really wanting the next life
and that's who I am but I wish no harm
for you
you know Allah told us that we cannot
force people to our way we can only
explain it to them and it's their call
let's leave it this way one more one
more before we get into our main topic
but he says look what your religion now
from what they've been told we know this
is falsehood
he says teaches you to strap a bomb on
yourself blow down buildings 9/11 and
you know just cause havoc on earth this
Islam teach this that's all bogus bogus
I like you picked up a bow that's bogus
yeah let's look at the text okay don't
don't just listen in any religion there
are people who you know take it out of
context in in religion Christianity and
Judaism let's inspect let's look at the
text what the text teaches and I'm
willing to entertain that if we want to
debate this yeah their religion the
sanctity of the human life does not
differentiate between a Muslim and
non-muslim every human life has a
sanctity and you as a Muslim is required
to observe and keep that sanctity you
cannot take the life of another person
unjustly it's out of line aslam has
nothing to do with you now we're gonna
we're gonna end with that note for until
we get back here on the Deen show don't
go anywhere we have much more to discuss
with shaikh abdul kareem be right back
and if we're gonna worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the religions
I remember find another meaning of what
Islam is war Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator
back here on the Dean show with our
special guests and we are gonna be I
open the show I said look you're going
through drama you're going through hard
times we all are it's a test we know
that but when you have the creator on
your side it's a smooth ride right right
so now the person is like his life
sucked upside down his children are
disobeying them the kids are swearing
cursing disrespecting the parents you
know it's all havoc but then when you go
these are Muslim individuals and we're
not trying to just you know disparage on
anybody put nobody down but we want to
evaluate so we can give the proper
medicine right and Islam has all the
cures and all the solutions for all the
ills that are out there now when you
talk and you have your an imam you talk
to the people do you see that when you
start talking to some people about their
life you see like you evaluate you ask
questions and one of the main things is
they not even making this a lot and
you're wondering why your your house is
upside down you didn't teach your
children to submit to the creator and
now there's some into all the pop stars
the movie stars and now you wondering
why you have hell in your house Islam is
like a medicine Eddie you have to take
it you have to swallow it in order to
get well you cannot pretend to be one
you have to walk the walk like they say
in America you have to fulfill the
commands and do it with the intention of
pleasing your Lord and you will see the
impact of this I run a you know a
question and answer show and I get
people calling you all the time
Muslims about depression you know I know
I should direct them to somebody who can
give them medicine but if they call the
ship that means they are looking maybe
for some help from a religious
perspective you know the first question
I ask them as do you pray five times
wonderful question do you pray fight
that's your medicine yes you know the
answer is no Subhan Allah said okay
imagine that I'm a doctor
ahaha okay I'm going to write a
prescription right here for you pray
five times I know you called me I me I'm
not a doctor I'm sure they're referred
for depression I'm I don't want to
dismiss that there are some medical
treatment for it I'm not
is missing that but he called the ship
he called an email so I told him he is a
prescription pray five times and please
visit me in two months that's that's the
way that's the way it is that if you
want to benefit you see when you submit
to Allah he will have that harmony
probably I'm talking to non-muslims you
see look how we are fashioned you're
made of two components together body and
soul to to boot together okay the
profits on Allah are the sellers told us
that when we become a sperm and then you
know after 120 120 days in the womb of
the mother then an angel comes and blows
the soul and in that little flesh and
then we die how we die when the soul
leaves the body okay let's leave
everything here and listen how do you
notice your body what do you do what do
you eat eat drink workout yeah what
about the soul have you ever thought
that your soul needs food your soul
needs nourishment you know the
nourishment of the soul of submission
submission to God that is why when you
pray you feel at peace when you recite
the Quran you feel at peace when you
fast you feel at peace anytime that
because you're nourishing your soul and
that is how you strike the balance
between the two the body and soul you
become happy and content you see we need
we need to be aware also that Satan is
smart he introduced some substance that
can help the soul but test side-effects
smoking weed makes you high mm-hmm
drinking makes you high but side effects
and it will kill you at the end because
it is the wrong nourishment for your
soul but the right nourishment a
submission and that's how it is and
that's how every Muslim need to look at
it if you're seeking happiness in this
world do the work that allah subhanaw
taala
asks you to do to show your submission
to allah subhanaw taala
and you will inherit the next life but
again do it in the basis of class
sincerity you're doing it for Allah
subhanAllah
now some people okay there they start
praying right
and they think they're gonna experience
now they're gonna be floating in the air
some you know because you see a lot of
these different groups up there and
mystics and that and you know they start
to you know have you thinking like
you're gonna be somewhere in the heavens
like ooh but now you're praying and the
guys like well I'm not okay you're
talking about you know I'm supposed to
be feeling something but it is it's
difficult you know I'm standing here I
got a prostrate go down and I'm not
floating in the air you know what I mean
so what's but what it's not working so
they stopped praying is this what we're
supposed to be experiencing you see it's
true isn't it it is very true yeah the
way that you presented is that that
approach is a weird approach well yeah
let me do something you know when Satan
refused to bow down to Adam and then he
was rejected yeah he said what - I will
be in the straight path for for for you
the children Adam any time that they
want to do goodness I will be out there
and there is a story that probably
mentioned in the books that some guy
came to Lima Hanifah rahim allah and he
said to him i have hidden a treasure
somewhere and and i don't remember
can he help me find it he said that he
man asked me about the fact or something
i can't stop but listen why don't you go
and wait say that again so he has to he
asked happy - abu hanifa a map yeah yeah
yeah it's a story that mention and so
he's asking I can't find I can't find my
treasure and he's I got time for that I
can't help you probably what but listen
I asked me about like not religious yeah
so but he said to him what why didn't
you go do this why didn't you go Miko do
and intend that you're gonna pray all
night tonight
mm-hmm Allah who act for the first raka
you know what he remembered where the
treasure is he left he did not even
complete the raka he left and he he just
left a pretty the wrong thing now yeah
Satan you see
inshallah Satan actually reminds you
with your problems and offers you the
best solutions mm-hmm and I'm sure the
viewers can relate to this
but after you say Salam alikoum Rocco
the line does allow you forget
everything
why because it's a struggle the presence
of the mind the presence of the heart
and this takes time to develop this
takes time to to reach that stage but at
the end of the day also you're not gonna
fly in the air or anything like that no
flying no no no please come on it's
enough that you feel that you're in
front of Allah find out that it's enough
that you you feel like you were speaking
to Allah a lot of Hannah Dallas is her
if Shia Muslim has every right a person
to so that I mean you know when I have
Dina's fine the Salah al fatiha and the
solar warden is a feta when my servant
says and hamdulillah Arab be lion I mean
then Allah says my servant has praised
me our rahman al rahim exalted me
Malachy only being glorified me actually
you speaking to Allah
enough why do we stand in the Salah was
supposed to look down and in the way we
will prostrate because Allah subhana
Allah is looking at you and you show
humility and humbleness when you
prostrate the closest position to Allah
that is enough you're the closest to the
Creator when you put your when you place
your forehead in the ground I'll clobber
my hakuna Abdullah rob-beee he was a JIT
facto gonna drive I got a pal in every
sauce on them the closest position -
Allah is when you prostrating so make a
lot of drops
enough that feeling that's your you know
out there and if you're going through
hardship you know help me some patients
you know if Allah Spanos Allah bless do
something say alhamdulillah or school of
it say hamdullah if you have made a
committed a sin ask Allah to forgive it
but enough that you're communicating
connecting with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala but flying up in the air come
on
so can it before we go to break is it
safe to say can we say that it takes
work ok yeah it takes work it takes
discipline but if you do it you'll feel
the benefits will come that's a
guarantee absolutely but you have to
come to Allah with a sincere heart since
your heart work on it work on it don't
give up don't give up don't give up you
may actually in
counter once a la that it's not
happening but then the next salat will
happen but if you keep working it keep
keep forcing it it will come focus try
to focus okay you see some people like
praying and then I you know looking
around what is it it's not accepted no
absolutely you've seen this guy praying
why is it looking at me the Prophet SAW
yeah a value of I mean you're far enough
what's wrong with people who raise their
other visions in the air no you're
supposed imagine you're standing in
front of a cup mm-hmm you're standing in
front of Allah imagine you're standing
in front of a cup will you look away no
yeah you're standing in front of a lot
of humble yourself and that is why
you're supposed also to have a suit run
from the Sutro prevent people yeah a
barrier to prevent people from that's
authentic hadith business absolutely
yeah absolutely
you could really overcome it by going to
the side you could do this it doesn't
have to be necessary but Sutra is the
ideal but basically you're don't want
some anybody to disconnect that
connection would you create this is what
you need five times a day imagine having
five times a day that's the prescription
now five times a day and if the doctor
gave you the prescription you take it a
law is giving it to you take it we'll be
right back with more here in Deen show
say to me why have you become a Muslim
no I give a very frivolous honest and I
say I want to be on the side of the
angels he's a number-one rap artist in
the world
he's sold over 60 million records
worldwide steve million he was a young
guy where basically everything that
somebody you would think that life is
all about he had everything you can
imagine
I am Not Afraid to stand alone if Allah
is by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
a box by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid
back here on addy show and we're talking
about the prescription the Salah the
prayer the one who has testified that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one who created everything in the
universe he's one and alone he doesn't
have a co-equal core partner as soon as
you put someone next to God you messed
the whole thing up isn't it that's the
pure monotheism Jesus is not God no
one's God and God is God and it's
beautiful beautiful is it feels good it
makes sense
it matches your fitrah it does I love
talking about it
well it's listen it's the way it is
that's how you feel and actually the
closest you see what mass this is the
society is the community is the the
people making up all these fairytales
about who God is but if you really check
out in your own self you know who God is
that is uniquely one he is not three
he's not made of no Sun no nothing of
that God is God and you know you brought
up the issue of the Salah you know they
define a man a man Eddie a man has two
ends heart which creed that you believe
in Allah oh Allah is who's the angels
are the set the six tenants of faith
Allah angels messengers books Qatar
lived resurrection yes so maintaining a
firm believe in those will lead to you
acting opponent acting like we're
talking about the Salah why Muslims are
negligent of the Salah when they know
the first question they will be asking
the Day of Resurrection is isola first
question the first question number one
number one question imagine imagine I'm
telling you you're gonna take a test on
Monday
I mean Monday is the beginning of the
week that's why I chose it but nothing
special about yeah and listen the first
test is so-and-so and you cannot take
the rest of the test without passing
that test and here is the answer what
you're gonna do you're gonna memorize it
word by word because if you mess up that
question if you must have the answer for
this question that means you're done the
prophet sallallaahu Allah says until
I will mail her Sawadee Hill abnormal
fear masala the first thing that a
person will be questioned about in the
difference of action is a salon if it is
sound they don't look at the list of
your deeds otherwise you know moving
forward done you're done so now I want
to take you back to the issue of the
Creed here that clear if that person
really the conditions on that day the
day for action it's miserable it's
miserable if he knows that he was going
to be standing in front of Allah the
prophet sallallaahu Allison I've had it
I didn't hockey mrs. Manion communi had
an ileus a Philemon
none of you but Allah will speak to
Allah will ask you about the Salah if
you let worthwhile human half an
astronaut of bahijon attend whoever is
concerned about standing in front of
allah and having to answer that question
why didn't pray five times oh well I had
the soap opera well I the football game
it always came at the time of the Salah
well I had your worshipping that yeah
yeah because you love that you'll love
that more than this yeah yeah so the
issue here is let's make sense this life
is short the prophet sallallaahu Lam
says the life span of my Ummah is
between 60 and 70 years old - eternity
but you could die tomorrow you could die
tomorrow and you could live more than
that but I'm talking about the overall
average overall average 60 is imagine
the de France of action is fifty
thousand years long subhanAllah fifty
tell the news long you're gonna be asked
about what you done and the first thing
that you're gonna be asking about is the
Salah
again I want to talk the Creed that's
the problem with a lot of Muslims a lot
of Muslims are not a wave of who Allah
is that when you stand in the solid
standing from front of allah subhanaw
taala that they are supposed to pray
because there is a day of resurrection
they don't know the events of that day
and that is why they are not mobilized
they are not motivated to pray five
times they say why should I pray because
he doesn't understand this an invitation
to those who do not pray go back and
study the Day of Resurrection and the
events of this day and you will see you
will wake up forfeitures on
to pray say only a few more questions
we're almost out of time tell us people
stand in line and I'm what they called a
Black Friday they want to get a 10% 20%
discount people 5:00 in the morning you
know about this day right right and
people are waiting and then you know
they want to get the new Michael
Jordan's and the store is open and they
like you know bum rush in each other and
they're up early Muslims in line - this
is a shame but fudger comes they don't
wake up so we want people to get up to
pray on time - to be committed to doing
the right thing so they don't have to
you mention 50,000 years waiting in line
tell us for the one who's humbled
himself in front of his Lord he's trying
to do the best that he can he's praying
five times a day and you know sincerely
you know doing his best will this day be
shortened for him well this is it may be
easy
it will feel different for the believer
Allah and that's how it is you know I
always go back to that that's a scary
thing you know you wait in line at the
post office or you can agitate it you're
like that come on no but man this day
will they believe or it will be listened
it will feel different
actually the prophets allah salla
mentioned that that duration before
reckoning it had if saved my headband
how do you have euphoria that eurasian
before rockin is going to feel like the
Sun is about to set until it sets but
for the believer but for the other one
standing for long actually they will
worry the prophets and the messengers -
please go intercede for a lot to begin
judgment they will actually request
their messengers they will go to ad and
then oh I can Abraham then mu said and I
said and Rasulullah saw some say o
Muhammad please let's get out of this
mess and rasool allah Salem would say AB
for it am for it I'm for it and he will
go to intercede for mankind even for the
people who make cartoons out of him they
will go bang him on that day that people
who make fun out of him that people who
call him all these names they will
actually make the Prophet sallallaahu
Ras as I'm in the day of resurrection to
take them out of that for allah subhanaw
taala to come in a way that fits him in
order to begin judgement last closing we
only got 30 seconds closing comments
suggestions for the people been
struggling with their identity
struggling to wake up for fudger you
know what they do everything else but
they're not working to please the crater
and we really got to get on the ball
because def is a reality just in 30
seconds what advice do you have for the
Prophet loves you he loves you dearly
he loves you dearly he's the only one in
the Day of Resurrection he will be
saying my followers my followers
mindfulness everyone else including the
friend of Allah ibrahim alaih-is-salaam
never seen I've seen FC nerfs he will be
saying on Matthew Matthew Matty you know
in his bed of death in his bed of death
he used to say what are you English into
the Salah
that is why you're unhappy come on come
on get on your feet
start praying I'll learn how to pray
start praying
you will see in a month or two how much
this will impact you and will impact
everyone around you including your own
family thank you say so much for us and
may Allah reward you thank you we thank
you and that was some wonderful advice I
mean think about it
deaf can approach us at any time turn
off the TV you can have a heart attack
you can go outside getting a car
accident deaf can reach you and you want
to be prepared and for the one who has
submitted to the crater alone and not
his creation worshiping only the one God
the one who created this whole universe
and everything in it the one who is
gonna judge you on a Jay a judgement did
you hear it did you hear that the first
thing you'll be asked about is the
prayer and if that's in line then we can
talk about the next but if it's not
there's nothing to talk about
so for the Muslims those who have
submitted to the will of God established
the prayer not for three two or one time
of day five times a day and connect with
the most loving the most kind the
creator of the heavens and earth connect
with him and he forgives all sins come
to him with a sincere heart but don't
disconnect because you'll be
disconnected be connected through the
prayer through this a lot and continue
to tune in here to the Deen show every
week we got the new dunya to dienes out
pick it up and if you'd like if this
your first time tuning in and you like
what we have to say and you want to
accept Islam or you want to get the
verbatim Word of God the Quran called
the number 1 800 662 and continue to
tune in here to the D show we'll see you
next time God 1 peace be with you